anybody see the movie it this weekend
yeah it was the number-one movie about a
dangerous clown who terrifies both
children and adults yeah and yet somehow
ends up getting elected president that's
the part speaking of it this is true in
Texas this weekend this was a huge movie
people love this movie in Texas this
week and they had a special event a
movie theater hosted a showing of the
movie it that was for an audience made
up entirely of clowns yeah yeah only one
car showed up but the place was packed
[Applause]
that one was from my mom you know I like
the clowns that don't murder yeah yeah
people in the South are still dealing
with hurricane Irma that's still going
on when asked about hurricane Irma
President Trump said this is some big
monster yeah
in other words Trump's plan to combat
hurricane Irma is fat-shaming it a
little heavy she could lose a few she
could lose a few over Twitter
I don't you saw this over Twitter
billionaire Richard Branson revealed the
damage done by the hurricane to his
private island yeah I know what you're
thinking
how could God allow such a thing Oh God
he's a billionaire yes his private
island destroyed sad I found that funny
you did not
[Applause]
apparently the crowd tonight is made up
mostly a billion Aryan everybody here
you know what I should have known when
everyone took their own Learjet to the
taping today that should have been the
giveaway right it was reported yesterday
that two people were arrested for
throwing a yoga mat at the White House
yeah when she heard this Melania Trump
said yoga mat I told him to throw me a
rope ladder
Pope Francis was in Latin America over
the weekend Pope Francis Andy I know you
keep track of his movements I do
Pope Francis in Latin America over the
weekend and he called it a moral
responsibility for everyone to fight
climate change or as Fox News reported
it Hispanic guy in dress wants to take
away your SUV that we got a lot of it
well they might say no no okay I'll clap
at that while in Colombia the Pope
bumped his head in his popemobile yeah
just just bumped his head he's fine but
he just bumped his head in the
popemobile yeah apparently no one
noticed because they're used to the Pope
yelling Jesus Christ
you
you